I got to imagine like as the multiverse
expands that means sooner later you know
you get Mikasa I want it so I keep
saying I'm like guys I look dope in
leather stop waiting it's weird watching
BOTS it's weird wonderful it's like
watching them do the flash on Broadway
hey everybody its charlie we need to
react to this iris West speedster
costume and we have some new information
about the episode we understand why she
gets powers now it's a little bit
different than I thought and I have some
news about Titans Nightwing Batgirl
there's a bunch of stuff to react to so
there is a new round of the flash ring
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
just be a subscriber and leave a comment
on the video flashed up first then we'll
talk about Titans in Nightwing so flash
episode 16 is called run iris run is
basically the iris as a speedster
episode the premise is is that the next
bus meta and I'm assuming it's the tenth
meta because we meet meta number 9 and
then episode 15 is the team up flash
family episode their name is melting pot
and their ability is swapping powers so
during an encounter Barry gets his
powers swapped with iris and then before
they can figure out how to reverse the
process another big problem comes up
that only iris with Barry's powers can
solve so Barry just has to coach her
through that boss fight then eventually
they figure out how to reverse the
process Barry gets his powers back iris
goes back to being normal so on so far
now there's obviously a whole lot of
other stuff that will be happening
during the episode I'm expecting some
coffee shop girl stuff to be happening
we don't have any details about how
that's gonna be involved with this but
this just changed a little bit about how
I'm thinking about this iris pregnancy
coffee shop girl storyline they didn't
say exactly why they gave her this
version of the costume I think just
because excess is an african-american
female speedster in the comics iris West
is an african-american female so they
probably just wanted to go with
something familiar that also looked
different from the other speedsters
we've seen so far like she probably
doesn't fit into Barry's costume and
they have some spare parts lying around
so Cisco Magic's up a costume overnight
they don't have the special lightning
bolt down the middle so maybe they add
that later at the end of the episode or
something like that or if it ever comes
back in a future season the bus meta
isn't somebody from the comics so I'm
assuming they had the idea for the twist
first and then they just created the bus
meta to fit that need like they wanted
to do a one
episode where iris West gets flash
powers so they needed a reason for her
to get those and up to this point my
theory was is that it would have
something to do with her pregnancy or
possible pregnancy because of what
happened with Cecile and because they've
been teasing that iris West might have
been pregnant for a long time now going
all the way back to that big crossover
episode pregnant women Felicity says
that iris is glowing and then Caitlin
correct sir no pregnant lady's glow like
very obviously trying to wink at the
fact that she either might become
pregnant or she might be pregnant at the
moment and just not realize it yet with
the writers and the producers don't
always tell you though is when they do a
lot of course correction so they may
have had the idea when they started the
season to get iris pregnant by the end
of the season and maybe they changed
their minds about that and wanted to
delay it just a little bit or they
wanted to change the way some of the big
character twists work because I think
this all gets back to coffee shop girl
people being pregnant this season Barry
and iris getting married the future
flash family like when you talk about
flash family obviously you have Jay
Garrick and Jesse quick coming up but
the literal flash family in the children
that Barry and iris will eventually have
but just be prepared for them to take a
couple left turns because it is a
minefield trying to do children on a TV
show like this when your main actors are
this young and you're still only about
midway through your series run like
flash goes eight to ten seasons they're
only about halfway right now but it's
really hard to do people like Bart Allen
without explaining the Barry and iris
get married and have children like you
have to tease that along for people that
don't read the comics you can't just
have them show up and be like hey I'm
your grandchild wait a minute when did
we get married when did we have children
when did those children have children so
they don't want to skip over too many
big character moments but again I think
the coffee shop girl will show up again
we'll get some more hints about what her
backstory is and who she is specifically
even though I think they did a good job
of explaining her being part of Barry
Allen and irises family
always pays no worse but moving into
Nightwing Batgirl DC movie territory you
may have heard Joss Whedon left the
Batgirl movie it sounds like it's
indefinitely delayed I think they still
want to make one but he basically said
it took me a couple months to realize
that I didn't have a story so there's
not a lot to say about that I feel like
the Internet is probably going to be
fine with that they were already upset
with Joss Whedon for a number of
different reasons after Justice League
that being said now it's a little bit
easier for any of the potential TV shows
to use the Barbara Gordon character
which is good news for Titans because
they're already doing Robin Robin has
such a close connection with Barbara
Gordon in the comics I am very hopeful
that they could bring her on that show
eventually the Nightwing movie also
sounds like it's going to be delayed so
Chris McKay the person that's been
directing that is now in the running to
do a Dungeons & Dragons movie which
would be released before the Nightwing
movie meaning that he would either have
to quit the Nightwing movie or just put
it on a shelf for a couple years and
come back to it so the early estimate
right now is that the Nightwing movie
won't come till 2023
which is actually good news for the
Titans TV show doing Nightwing because
we pick up with that series we know he's
gonna start out as Dick Grayson Robin in
at least a flashback then he'll slowly
transition and take the mantle of
Nightwing over the course of that series
whether it goes five seasons seven
seasons he takes the mantle in the last
couple of seasons
so the Nightwing movie isn't gonna drop
till they get to like season four of
Titans so they have plenty of time to do
what they want with Nightwing like you
may have heard that arrow isn't allowed
to use the destro character because
they're trying to develop a Deathstroke
movie with Joe Manganiello whether or
not it ever actually ends up happening
in the Batman movie is obviously still a
long ways off - so just a couple DC
movies have been back-burnered but not
canceled like they're still gonna do a
back row movie eventually they'll still
do a Nightwing movie but never fear
because we have Titans coming and you
can do most of those characters on the
Titans TV show in some form or another
but let me know in the comments they
delay that how do you want them to use
the Barbara Gordon character on Titans
do you want her to be full-blown Batgirl
do you want her to be in the wheelchair
and be more of the Oracle character do
you just want her to be like a Roy
Harper
type and show up every once in a while
or do you want her to come on full-time
now they got so many characters in
season one that I not expecting to see a
lot of Barbara Gordon but maybe season
two season three like they talked about
maybe doing Donna Troy I don't think
she's gonna be a big thing till season
two obviously there's the question of
speedsters on Titans it's a little hard
to predict where they're going without
having seen any of the episodes yet so
like I said trailer for Titans probably
won't drop till early summer just
because they're right around Episode
five Episode six right now there's 13
episodes total they'll probably wait
till they have most of the footage from
the season done the latest they would
wait would be Comic Con so bare minimum
you will see Titans footage by Comic Con
but I don't think that you'll have to
wait that long I'm working on a new soul
gem video that should post tomorrow but
leave all your requests in the comments
below DC Marvel anything else I also
just saw some really cool news about the
Deadpool TV series so I might do a video
about that too but just a reminder that
all the TV shows are coming back next
week so everything including wally west
on legends is back next week on him that
new giveaway winner when I post new DC
so click here for my Black Panther 2
video learn all about Marvel phase 4 and
click here for all my black panther
Easter eggs thank you so much for
watching everybody to stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight